[Music]
in 1796 Thomas Jefferson received a box
of bones he couldn't identify a long
sharp claw reminded him of a lion but
the arm bones suggested a larger animal
one about three meters long
thinking it might be a huge unknown
species of North American lion Jefferson
warned explorers Lewis and Clark to keep
an eye out for this mysterious predator
but Jefferson's box of bones didn't come
from a lion they came from an extinct
giant sloth prehistoric ground sloths
first appeared around 35 million years
ago dozens of species lived across North
Central and South America alongside
other ancient creatures like mastodons
and giant armadillos some ground sloths
like the mega Lana kid were cat sized
but many were massive Jefferson sloths
megalonyx weighed about a ton and that
was small compared to megatherium which
could reach 6 metric tons as much as an
elephant
they ambled through the forests and
savannas using their strong arms and
sharp claws to uproot plants and climb
trees grazing on grasses leaves and
prehistoric avocados in fact we might
not have avocados today if not for the
giant sloths smaller animals couldn't
swallow the avocados huge seed but the
sloths could and they spread avocado
trees far and wide ground sloths
flourished for millions of years but
around 10,000 years ago they started
disappearing along with the western
hemispheres other giant mammals
researchers think that ground sloths
could have been pushed out by an
oncoming ice age or competition with
other species maybe humans who arrived
in the region around the time most of
the sloths went extinct some of the
smaller sloths did survive and migrated
to the treetops today there are six
species left
living in the rainforest canopies of
Central and South America hanging out in
the trees is a good way to avoid
predators and there are plenty of leaves
to eat but this diet has its drawbacks
animals extract energy from food and use
that energy to move around maintain
their body temperature keep their organs
working and all the other activities
necessary for survival but leaves don't
contain much energy and that which they
do have is tough to extract most
herbivores supplement a leafy diet with
higher energy foods like fruit and seeds
but sloths especially three-toed sloths
rely on leaves almost exclusively
they've evolved finely-tuned strategies
for coping with this restricted diet
first they extract as much energy from
their food as possible sloths have a
multi chambered stomach that takes up a
third of their body and depending on the
species they can spend five to seven
days or even weeks processing a meal the
other piece of the puzzle is to use as
little energy as possible
one-way slots do this is of course by
not moving very much they spend most of
their time eating resting or sleeping
they descend from the canopy just once a
week for a bathroom bark when sloths do
move it's not very fast it would take a
sloth about five minutes to cross an
average neighborhood street this
unhurried approach to life means that
sloths don't need very much muscle in
fact they have about 30% less muscle
mass than other animals their size
sloths also use less energy to keep
themselves warm because their body
temperature can fluctuate by about 5
degrees Celsius less than a cold-blooded
reptile but more than most mammals these
physical and behavioral adaptations
minimize the sloths energy expenditure
or metabolic rate three-toed sloths
have the slowest metabolism of any
mammal the giant panda is second slowest
and two-toed sloths come in third moving
slowly has allowed sloths to thrive in
their treetop habitats but it's also
made the sloths themselves a great
habitat for other organisms including
algae which provides a little extra
camouflage and maybe even a snack sloths
may not be giant anymore
but that doesn't make them any less
remarkable
[Music]
you